bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got
jessica here with me
uh she has never been on zoom before so
we're gonna give this a try
uh thank you so much for doing this yeah
absolutely thanks for giving me a reason
to download it
i was kind of resistive but i couldn't i
couldn't deny your
invite so here i am you
uh you have a very different background
than almost anybody else i've ever had
on the podcast
let's start just with where did where
were you born where'd you grow up and
how did you get into
modeling uh photography et cetera
um well i'm from kansas so i did
20 years of hard winter and decided i
didn't want snow anymore
so graduated college after uh doing my
undergraduate
moved away did the hollywood
uh dream thing so lots of photo shoots
lots of production i'm a photographer
now but
um moved out here to do modeling hair
and makeup just
you know the hollywood thing so when you
say the hollywood thing
how exactly does this work i think
people are fascinated with if you go to
hollywood and
uh you talk to every waiter waitress uh
bar hop etc like everyone's trying to
break into acting
modeling uh or some aspect of that like
how did you
break into that industry and like what
is that life like
well um no two days are ever the same
which is a part of the
fun of it i guess the appeal so um
we did it's hard because
it's already been a year that i haven't
had my normal life so
it's sort of bittersweet to think back
to all the great things about it
um that aren't afforded to us right now
so um
it was a lot of castings a lot of
media events a lot of
production days that were long and i i
do all kinds of things so
it was just fun to squeeze in on
production however i could and i started
doing uh
sports media for combat sports and that
was really fun
so i just sort of could squeeze in
wherever
my interest led me so that was a cool
thing about
the opportunities in hollywood all right
so let's separate these out let's first
talk about the modeling
uh part of it um what is that like on a
day-to-day basis so forget kind of the
other aspects of what you would do
like just from a modeling standpoint is
it you show up to a shoot and
literally it's like six hours and they
just take pictures of you the whole time
is that weird um it was weird for
a couple years i traveled around the
country and i would just
self-fund my tour across america and
shooting and
the world was just different when i
started in 2008
so um once i parked it in l.a sure it's
a little more
this is a little more structured but you
build a network and then you start doing
projects with people that
you're comfortable with creating and um
you start just cross-promoting each
other and so i really work with the same
core group of people
a lot of the times and we just diversify
and pull each other in on projects we're
doing so
so you mentioned being comfortable with
the people you work with uh
if somebody asked me to go and uh and be
a model i would have
uh all of my clothes on and probably
it would be the least eventful uh photo
shoot in the world
uh yeah by your wife yeah yeah exactly
like you know
my wife would actually be the one
directing it etc yes
and uh and she probably would be telling
me i'm an idiot uh for even trying
anything
she's a good cheerleader for you
well if you watch lunch money then you
already know exactly how
how that would go down i pretty much
would do uh
nothing that i wanted to do uh but in
terms of
uh the modeling that you did a lot of it
when you're going across the country
was unstructured it sounds like then you
get to la it's a lot more structured
you're talking about like kind of being
comfortable
you eventually end up doing much more
with playboy
and all that like how do you get
comfortable with people
is it weird like that's just like a
foreign concept to
95 99 of people like what is that like
well it's been so long since i had to
think about it that it's that it's uh
hard to articulate it and
because pretty much my existing network
is all people that are already in it so
i guess i never make that um that
explanation
it's not unlike anything else when you
do it i mean
you know when you somebody goes to war
they just get used to the things that
come with that
so this was just a different kind of war
different battle
you know normalizing some things and
so um i don't know it's
it's hard to think back to it i i just
accepted that that was the path i picked
to have the ticket out of my hometown so
after graduating college i just decided
to
go model which is strange but
hey one of the things that's fascinating
about this
is uh as a ticket out of your hometown
if you decide okay i'm gonna go do this
what's the reaction from your family
from friends you can go to college with
is it one of uh support is it something
that's so outside of their
like framework of a job that they are
jealous
they're uh agnostic to it like what was
that
well i didn't ask anybody's permission
i didn't require anybody's support
and if you're not a person that requires
those things then
you can break free of the mold that's
made for you
so i didn't want to stay in kansas and i
didn't
want to do that um
now with the the city having changed
some i can see the appeal of that a
little more than i
would before the shutdown so um
but i feel like people have to get it
out of their system if they want to go
and do something you've got to go check
it out because otherwise you'll just
wonder
yeah my true friends
my true support system they didn't care
they now they didn't bring it up all the
time they didn't want to hear stories
they don't go like
my pictures that type of thing which is
fine that's not what i needed from my
real world friends you can always make a
digital community that supports you and
what you create so yeah that's that's
it's there's been a a bit of a divide
come from a
pretty conservative background my
parents weren't
too thrilled but we just didn't make it
a big talking point they were just happy
i made it to 18.
all good so coming from a conservative
family and then ended up
in playboy i'm sure was uh it was a
challenge to navigate
but uh it sounds like you figured it out
uh talking about the
good well now i'm navigating the
opposite terrain having been a playboy
in hollywood you know that type of thing
and then and then changing politically
to more
center-right that comes with its own
uphill battle that was
reminiscent of coming from a
conservative family
in a red state and then going off and
you know posing naked that type of thing
so it's a similar experience it's
parallel
we'll get to your second uh transition
here in a second
but uh the playboy experience
i am sure that uh if you get into
modeling it is
uh almost like the pinnacle i almost
look at it like uh
if you play basketball you want to play
in the nba if you play
football you want to play in the nfl as
a model that seems like that is
uh kind of the aspirational uh
achievement what was that
like uh any regrets positives negatives
just how do you kind of view that now
that
you don't spend a lot of your time doing
it
i just accepted it as the terms of
modeling that it was no
even supermodels don't get out of the
game without posing naked in some
capacity so
that part wasn't ever really a concern
for me in fact if you're going to do it
you may as well go all in
so i looked at people like jenny
mccarthy and and you know
melania trump and people like that it's
it's like you can
of course pose for playboy and then move
beyond it
into whatever domain you want and it's a
good launching platform
so everybody has to come from somewhere
it's fascinating to me to think about
uh and i don't even know if you realize
this like the thought process that
uh even the supermodel ends up uh
modeling naked at some point but
people being able to transition past
like you mentioned uh
when it's coming up are you nervous
are you uh worried at all do you think
about like oh my friends my family etc
here's what they're going to think
or is it from a political or a
professional standpoint
uh it is the epitome and kind of that
achievement and so
you're more focused on this professional
goal and everything else
figured out as a cops well i wanted to
um do the commercial aspects of posing
for magazines like playboy and fhm
and there was a whole series of other of
other magazines
but i i just wanted to do that to
legitimize the fact that for two years i
had already been modeling
so i had already done sexy photo shoots
and lingerie and all that
so i i guess i just wanted to
commercially validate my
endeavor so and it was good for
marketing after the fact
because then your brands want to use you
in that how that whole thing ascends
so this sounds nuts but as i hear you
talking uh
you're basically describing what now
everyone is like yelling and screaming
all excited about it's like the creator
economy right it's these people who
they build some large audience and then
they're able to monetize it afterwards
really what you're talking about almost
you know a decade decade and a half ago
is
uh as you're coming up in the modeling
world you end up getting into
playboy that's like a stamp of approval
or validation
of that career and then you're able to
launch that into
other business endeavors is that kind of
a fair comparison
exactly and everybody wants to put
somebody else in
you know a bottle a container that they
can understand and
and it's been it's been so long that now
i've been interested in so many other
things that
i feel like i've shattered that mold
enough but i still go to the well enough
to support the
fact that that's why people follow me
but it's it's been really great to just
grow an audience and then
whoever wants to stick around for the
conversation can or
you know if not i'll still still
push the pictures and that type of thing
so i i know why people came but that
isn't necessarily why they stayed so
but uh no i appreciate the fact that
it's been it's
that i got a little bit of a head start
on the game um the only bad excited
about coming from doing it before the
creator economy
was is that i didn't necessarily see the
market potential for some of these
things because i had been so used to
just
giving away my product on online just to
build a community around because we
weren't
um really community building in 2008 so
much
i mean i was just in artist communities
growing in that space
just there was there was social media
networks that were just for
models and photographers to connect so
we could create in our own little world
instead of things that were so wide open
like instagram for everybody to consume
so yeah it's fascinating to me that uh
you know if you'd almost done that today
uh in one viewpoint uh it's almost taboo
at this point right it seems like
there's a lot more uh
social pressures and the way that uh
some of those activities and
uh publications et cetera are reviewed
is very different than it was a decade
or 15 years ago
at the same time uh you being the model
actually in the content uh there's way
more tools available for you to actually
build an audience capture the audience
monetize the audience and so yeah
uh they don't see it
and they don't see it coming explain
that yeah
well some people are just taken by
surprise i guess my
diverse interests but everybody is
always uh
everybody has a whole universe inside
them and obviously everybody has
potential to
grow and find new interests so
um it's fun to just sneak up on people
and pop some
stuff in like people are often surprised
that you know i'm a mixed martial artist
fan
yeah and and so i guess from the
publication side uh
are they in trouble with things like
only fans
or streaming platforms or uh the ability
for whether it's models or other kind of
content creators to go direct to
audiences
or is there still some kind of moat that
they have in terms of that stamp of
approval right if there's people who
want to be in modeling today do they
still want to go
and be featured in playboy or do they
just say i don't even need that i can
just go direct to an audience and
monetize it that way
like what do you see happening there
i think that it's still a novelty to be
associated with brands
but also the brands that um are
leveraging models or online
personalities
has opened up so much um you know makeup
campaigns for just beauty bloggers
because of their wide audience and the
reach that they have so
um the power has just shifted to
creators and that's a really nice
thing because we can validate with stats
the reach that we're going to have
for a company to um choose us as opposed
to somebody
one of the other you know 90 people that
are just like us
but maybe better yeah so if i talk to
you in 2008
like maybe the early 2010s and i said
what do you do
for a living how would you have
described it would you have said i'm a
model
uh i'm a playmate like what would you
have described then
and knowing that it's probably changed
but how did you originally think of it
um well i would uh sit for artists and
sculptors and painters and
photographers mostly and they would work
from those images that we would make but
um the community was just was just small
i mean i was a
starving artist for a long time so it's
nice to not be that
so much these days uh yeah
and and so if we fast forward to today
uh i think that you have tapped into
many other different audiences and it
sounds like a lot of those audiences are
coming out of your
personal interests right so we can start
with mma and there's bitcoin and
um and now even uh you know kind of
broader macroeconomics and government
but mma seems to be the first thing that
you kind of transition to
or sort of talk about outside of the
arts or the creative work
where does that interest come from and
like how did you
uh navigate that transition was it
something that was very strategic and
thoughtful or did one day you just start
tweeting about
mma and said hey look you know i don't
care what people think
well i would watch the fights with a
friend a playboy photographer kind of
funny
um but um yeah i just watched really
loved it
got enamored with the game you start
investing in individual sports are so
much different than
than team sports because you get to know
the players so much more
intimately and they do a pretty good job
of
brand building the individuals so
especially with social media
and so you become more engaged in their
game i guess
so um i just
love that i fell in love with it i don't
really know what to say other than that
but
this space was so wide open especially
when i started to shoot pictures because
then
i was getting ringside access and cage
side
opportunities to shoot for amateur and
um some professional
uh league so yeah it was fun so i i just
saw the opportunity i've done the
red carpet run roll camera for you know
ufc hall of fame
and just these interviews and media days
the day before that they you know when
they do their weigh-ins and stuff so
um it was just an opportunity to go
leverage my modeling but then contribute
in a different kind of way
and i just loved the scene and it was
different and i relate to
fighters in their stories and um
overcoming obstacles in the journey and
seeing the hard work like i find them so
inspiring
because we're all we're all fighting for
something
what are you fighting for oh
well such a big idea right um
you have to i um in in
shattering the mold that was made for me
as
you know a little farm girl in kansas
that was never supposed to leave and get
out and certainly not
get to um break
break the need to have a job and people
to
have to please all the time like i i
speak my mind and i say exactly what i
mean
probably too too far of a degree because
i don't have really any accountability
in that way but that's what freedom is
to me
so i guess the what i'm fighting for is
building something where nobody can take
that for me
in a world where people are constantly
seeking to
invalidate your humanity for not having
a mainstream opinion
and perspective on things and so when
you think about the
transition uh around mma some of that
was personal interest
you enjoyed watching you enjoyed talking
about it uh but you also had somewhat of
a career change there it sounds like you
went from being the subject of the
photography
to actually being the photographer in
many cases you were capturing the
content
was that um anything kind of driving
that or was it just you were
familiar with cameras and had one and
want to start taking pictures like
what drove that transition i found that
i had all this access
and i picked up a camera to not waste
the access that i had
so that worked with mma because i was
just i was just getting such
um positive results and access to
fighters and
making friends with journalists and they
were just people i wanted to be around
and i like i said i find the
fighter stories so just inspiring
um so it was a way to enhance my hobby
and also
it gave me a reason to find a new way to
be a creator so i picked up a camera
because i didn't want to waste the
opportunity
fumbled my way through it nobody seemed
to even notice i was fumbling my way
through
the beginnings of it so um
it is just one i just i i had time to do
it and i
always loved new challenges and being
able to
um just absorb information so
it just it was just something that i i
felt like doing and so i did it and
that's the
that's been the best thing that modeling
has afforded me in this
lifestyle is is that i can go all in on
anything i'm interested in
so uh i'm noticing a trend here which
it sounds like basically you said hey
as a playboy playmate i can get my foot
in the door
when i get my foot in the door i have
this incredible access and in a very
opportunistic way you knew
that if you had your foot in the door
had access and you brought a camera with
you you could almost launch an entirely
new career
and not break them all from going from
kansas to
l.a but also break the mold from being
the playboy
model to now being somebody who's
actually creating the content
photographers that fair that's very fair
yeah and it can and it just it keeps
opening my world
up so much so if if you're bringing
value to other people
then they'll open doors for you too so
yeah it's nice because it feels the
world feels so big and wide open
okay so this is fascinating because uh
it sounds like you had this
second career if you will that was
taking off covet happens
everyone's ordered to go sit in their
houses pretty much everything that you
had done up until that point
was destroyed right there's no photo
shoots
whether you're in front of the camera or
behind the camera like it all just goes
to zero
what's your reaction when that occurs
how do you think about it
and what did you do well
um i had what is commonly called a red
pilled moment
so it gave me the opportunity to
question everything i thought i believed
and that's quite the uh paradigm shift
it it happened suddenly but
but incrementally um
but i had something
traumatic you know with the shutdown
happens because because
all of my income was gig economy and
um you know freelance finding my finding
my way and
i did so many things but there has to be
international travel
and there has to be live events and
there has to be that ecosystem to
support
you know free market
opportunities um so
all like suddenly all my income turned
off
because i've done the internet
monetization or anything
like that i was just happily enjoying my
life and then all of a sudden it came to
a screeching halt
and then they started doing things like
turning people's power and water off if
they were
gathering in their homes and all these
just things that made me
really need to go look at what i thought
about
size of government and those types of
things
okay so before we get into the the
finance and government side uh
let's just talk about from like a
business perspective okay
you've got a great business multiple
streams of income everything's going
awesome
covet happens income goes to zero what
do you do
do you try to just scramble and figure
out online and
like other types of revenue channels
what did you
had to kind of nap well it was tough at
least i had i had some savings
from the years so i
burned through that in about six months
and i was astonished that
we weren't over this yet
so um
i was angry you know it's hard to not be
and so when you think about like that
anger is that coming from
uh you're angry that there's the
shutdown you're angry at yourself
that you had everything kind of in the
analog world like
what was driving that anger well i i was
always aware that anything
could come bring my freelancing to
a screeching halt but it was never
supposed to be government it was never
they were never supposed to create
problems for me
um but i was always aware that there was
no
there was no safety net for me because
that was the exchange that i had made
you know i wasn't
you know talk about risk aversion and
things like that i'm not a person that's
particularly afraid of those things
because they're always there
so then when i saw everybody's reaction
to you know this
the virus it it was
uh recalibrating of everything i thought
that was happening around me and so as
this plays out
uh you said you had kind of this red
pill moment
what were the things that maybe um were
antithetical to what you previously
believed or the
changes in opinion that you had as uh
ssl played out
well uh size of government and their
ability to
um the whole emergency powers and being
able to just make decisions for you
um
the transparency of the media brought
that
into question the amount of
coordination between nations
to just wave your hand and shut down the
world that was kind of
astonishing to me um there were things
that i had always heard conservatives
say
but i just hadn't had an opportunity to
see it in the world
to really point at that thing and say
this is what you know
over regulation looks like i've heard
people say that but i didn't really know
what
that meant and is it fair to say that
this is a huge over generalizations or
correctness
i think los angeles and southern
california is generally seen as
a very liberal leaning uh type of
geographic region uh people for the most
part it seems like
we're hey the government is going to see
this government is uh has the right
solutions the government is going to
step in here
uh and so this red pilling that you went
through
almost kind of went counterfactual to
or was a narrative violation to those
around you right it seems like it's
almost like
well the majority of people felt one way
you started to again break the mold and
think for yourself to some degree right
yes and that's frowned upon
which explain why why is it frowned upon
well it's frowned upon because
um they don't would would prefer that
you not
challenge any of those beliefs
because it leads other people to doing
the same and i didn't know
that disagreeing was going to cause me
to lose
um opportunities and friends
even family members that type of thing
but um it will and that's
i feel like that's um contrary to the
entire
concept of freedom of speech and freedom
of opinion and
you know diversity of thought and
um that opened my eyes to to a lot and
the problems with mob mentality
cancel culture it just opened up a door
to everything because if you agree with
things like the shutdown
then they the left just turns its back
on you entirely and it just eats itself
in that way so
i guess i'm just a product of the fact
that i had a disagreeing opinion
for shutting the economy down locally
and um then people make
me the bad guy in that situation which
is crazy because i have no
institutional powers whatsoever what
does it really matter what i say or
think
when you say uh people make you the bad
guy uh
is this more like industry
friends and kind of forces or more of
like the social media world
uh and people you know being toxic or
whatever online
well you can always minimize the latter
by not
talking about it a lot but it was all i
was thinking about so
and i was i was having my own journey it
was more like a public
um an opportunity for me to digest
what was happening and my evolution it
was just publicly happening because a
lot of it was
the the ideas and the arguments were
coming from
you know online but yeah i changed my
entire media sources and
um the people i followed and engaged
with and
yeah it was really recalibrating
um and you could never and you can never
undo it
what was the uh what was the most
surprising part of all of this
and i asked that as um uh i think that
there's some people who had a starting
point
uh that was like halfway down the the
red pilling
uh pathway and then this all exasperated
it
but you strike me as somebody who uh
went through the
full experience right from kind of start
to finish
um during this and so what was the most
surprising uh
thing that you kind of took away from
from that experience
oh other other people's
unwillingness to let you change and be
fine with it
because everybody has this little
characterization of
who who you are they're not actually
able to really roll with the fact that
you're going to evolve because usually
evolution is slow
but this happened rather aggressively i
mean i can benchmark it from a one year
point
so i sound different every all my
interests are different my perspectives
of history i had to relearn
everything i ever believed historically
you know so when people hear that uh
there's two new schools of thought uh
the people who agree with you
are gonna say uh amazing she
uh you know was taught one thing she
thought one way that's the incorrect way
of thinking and now she's seen the light
and look how smart she is because she
agrees with
you know what we agree with the people
who disagree
with the way you think now uh say oh my
god she changed her information sources
she created an echo chamber what an
idiot
like you know that's the problem in
america
and uh we've gotta prevent that from
happening to the masses
right uh i always laugh uh i'm literally
laughing as i see the question because
it feels like those two extremes
uh obviously provide like the truth
somewhere in between there
and so like walk us through from like
almost like an executioner application
standpoint of like when you say you
change your information sources like
what were they what did you change them
to
uh what were the types of people that
you started to consume content from that
you hadn't been from before uh just
whatever you can share on that front
well i wouldn't want to risk getting
your video demonetized or
get you in trouble so i'm trying to edit
myself
to uh you can say listen you can say
whatever you want to say don't worry
about
uh uh monetization on youtube which by
the way the fact that that's the first
thing you think of
uh may be part of the problem well um i
you know and i'm not a youtuber and i
don't rely on that but
or any i don't rely on brand
endorsements or or any of that
that was one great thing that made me
have
um be in the right situation where i
could speak my mind and and
i realize how many people can't or
aren't allowed
to people message me and say hey i agree
with your politics but i'm afraid i work
in hollywood and you know that won't go
well and so it was just really
surprising to me the amount of people
that
want to but can't and and then i saw
that phenomenon and i was like well it
means i need to speak even more
so that brings us to uh the topic that
everyone is wondering which is bitcoin
uh how the hell did you come across
bitcoin and
why did you become interested um well i
had learned about it just from observing
i've had friends that are into it and
they'll make posts and i would read it
but i didn't understand that i didn't
have a necessity for it
until the shutdown came and and then the
stimulus has
started happening and then you learn
about the fed and you can't audit it and
all these things and and like i said all
this happened to me in a year
the evolution of all of this because i
couldn't have
cared less about finance
so i had to learn a lot really fast
um but i had nothing to do so that was
the upside since los angeles was shut
down i had nothing
but time and new resources than educated
so um
now i see the necessity of it how you
get there
just wanting money that they can't ruin
i mean i don't
i'm not somebody that's amassed a lot of
uh private property
you know i have a ford and a french
bulldog it's not like i have a lot of
value to
to protect or you know transition my
assets or something but it was just the
principles like the fact that people
can wave their hand and stop the world
and and destroy people's ability to make
a living
and they can wave their hand and change
you know the
geopolitics of what's happening in other
countries and
and then they can actively dilute the
dollar that's in your bank account that
you've already worked for
the and renegotiate essentially
renegotiate the the wage you
worked for in the retroactively that
seemed so crazy to me
uh you you definitely were not red pill
you were orange pill
because uh you're you're speaking the
language uh
in terms of um this kind of learning
journey
right and it really does sound like you
uh kind of went through an evolution of
understanding and uh and frankie kudos
to you because it sounds like you were
actually very thoughtful not only of
understanding
what's happening right now but you went
back in history and started to
understand why i have certain things
uh happened and created the situation
that we're in today
um why talk about it publicly right
because you could have said hey you know
what i've got a bunch of free time
i'm gonna educate myself okay cool now
i'm educated uh you know what i think i
should buy some bitcoin
uh i think i should change my thoughts
and uh
you could have done that all in private
with no risk to your career
or anything else yeah you chose to talk
about it and talk about it quite a bit
it's like why do that well i didn't know
where it was heading
just publicly discussing the shutdown
when it all happened obviously everybody
was
talking about it for for the most part
but i didn't know
necessarily one thing would lead to
another like it would and then you find
yourself in your
in the next discovery and understanding
of what's going on
leads you to the next step like it took
me a a year
of the process before i bought bitcoin
which was what like two weeks ago
wasn't even that long ago so that i mean
thought it just takes a while for
thought to get you to action
and i was just ready to ease the depres
because i was
depressed about the political landscape
and
and um the uh social engineering i was
witnessing
uh and and i guess the more i witnessed
and was a
became aware of those things the more i
felt compelled that i had to say
these things that other people weren't
going to say or at least not people in
my
little domain of the internet so but
like i said a lot of it
a lot of my understanding came from
those online discussions
yeah so as many people go ahead
well i should say it's fascinating to
hear you kind of talk about how
impactful uh the online education the
information was to that journey
absolutely right yeah thank you thank
goodness thank goodness for youtube
educators and people who want to give
away what they know
like yourself because i i don't think i
would have always
connected the two i just had an
existential crisis with
what's happening in my country and
specifically my state and then to
you know have witnessed places like
texas and florida fully functioning
and i was like i want that kind of
leadership uh
why can't you know and then everything
that descended from that
i guess just led me to bitcoin yeah
uh you described it almost as a parallel
economy very kind of the digital
uh world and digital currencies and uh
protocols
uh how do you look at earning moving
forward
is it something where the work that you
do uh you'll ask to
be paid uh in bitcoin or other digital
currencies will you basically take a
portion of what you get paid and convert
it
like does anything change or is it more
just an awareness of hey there's kind of
these two economies that are parallel
uh and you'll exist in both of them but
it won't necessarily change
perspective well i i started the
daydream of two parallel economies
um because i wanted to be free of things
like cancel culture
and i wanted to you know go and and
you know gina carino and make sure that
she had a job even though she
now can't have a job with disney and and
and
candace owens and people like that that
just get
accosted online in their and their
opportunities removed for nothing other
than their
opinions so i wanted to i wanted to go
back to the
land of where we were fine with having
diversity of thought
so i just wanted to go participate with
people that
wouldn't financially consequent each
other in this way
um but it's so new to me i've had
bitcoin for
for two weeks so it's sort of hard for
me to
have amassed the understanding of how it
is that i could possibly earn in bitcoin
but
it's just a willingness and it certainly
signals some confidence in it
and it's probably going to present new
opportunity i don't even know how you
can necessarily
earn in crypto yet so um
but i'm willing and just being willing
is going to
um bring opportunity i'm sure yeah
you you are very open-minded so uh i
congratulate you on next that is a
rare skill in today's world um what is
the response been
uh among other people in the various
communities that uh that you've worked
in and your friends in
uh as you've uh kind of talked about
more this publicly about bitcoin etc
has it been one that has been receptive
uh is it one that is
uh a little bit more uh kind of uh
abrasive
or uh or they have have they been
agnostic
uh to some of those um well um a couple
of my friends already were bitcoin
holders so and now
i don't really deal with people that
because i'm so public about
my i just assume people know that about
me now so
um i've been creating with during the
shutdown
it's it's been less opportunity for
growth but it's
made it to where you can have
small productions with just the people
that you know and that you're
comfortable with and that
are all on the same page with some
things otherwise you have
serious disagreements about what how
it's safe to operate your
space and those sorts of things so um
my the people that i consider my friends
today because it's changed a little bit
i may have just deepened ties with
people who were already
you know um right of center
they're that's what they believe it and
they and they but they don't need me to
have to
adopt all their beliefs they don't have
to buy bitcoin themselves to be fine and
never bring it up if they think it's
dumb they're
you know some people that aren't really
all that into it or like just don't
invest more than you can afford to lose
and that's a fair thing to say but
if the government's gonna make me take
their money you know i may as well do
something with it
i feel like it's a fun uh harmless way
to do something productive with free
stimulus money the government
is giving me that i don't even want you
know it's just
i don't know it makes me smile a little
bit in the you know the quiet moments
yeah it's fascinating to me uh one more
thing before i get into the rapid fire
questions
is uh i i saw this uh you tweeted
i couldn't stop laughing when i read it
uh you said that you thought the mma
community
were uh really great at memes but the
bitcoiners are the mean
masters uh explain that a little bit
more
because uh that that is a uh a topic i
uh really really think people
underestimated like the meme is the
message
but uh but talk a little bit about the
memes and the bitcoin
yeah yes well that is um what
familiarized me with the fact that there
was a whole
secret language and certain ways of
spelling things and all this it's just
been a fun
it's been a fun few weeks i gotta say um
it's definitely a crash course and
understanding the lingo and the the
nomenclature of of bitcoin so um i got
flooded with
people taking my pictures and giving me
laser eyes which was just so great i got
this whole like gallery of resurrecting
playboy pictures and taking my profile
picture and lasering it up so i got a
nice little art gallery a little
digital art gallery there made for me um
yeah but the memes are crazy
but people like put me in memes and make
names about me
being in bitcoin and i never had
experienced anything like that
but it's fun i'll save them and send
them to friends but for the ones that
can relate to those
so it's fun i had no idea how were the
meme masters
uh we prefer the terminology meme lords
but uh meme masters is uh is basically
the same thing right
yeah see but meme lords is is you have
to have you have to have the insider
language so thank you for that you'll
appreciate this i think elon musk was
asked in a uh
new york times or bloomberg article they
said you know uh you're a billionaire
uh you also like means but uh given the
choice would you rather be a billionaire
or a meme lord what would you choose and
he said meme lord which uh
will forever uh go down as one of the
great uh
comments i think in the uh professional
interview
i love how he doesn't take himself too
seriously all the time
you just reach a point of success where
you don't have to answer questions
in the right predictable way you know i
think that's why we like him so much
that is very very true um before i let
you go i'm actually three questions that
ask everybody
you'll get to ask me one at the end uh
the first is what is the most important
book that you've ever read
most important book i've ever read
um
so many so many great ones what do i
got i got my wall
oh
i need a minute two minutes okay oh you
know what um
uh tip tim ferriss uh four hour work
week
i would say pretty revolutionary for me
that's a that's a uh a great book and uh
obviously with a lot of what you were
doing before pandemic
uh makes sense uh second question is
sleep schedule comes from our friends
over at eight sleep they've got a
thermo-regulated bed
means that you can turn it really hot or
really cold uh nice to sleep like five
or six hours
uh i thought that was normal and then i
started sleeping on this thing and now
i'm like eight or nine hours completely
changed my life
and full-on convert of the sleep
religion uh
what is your sleep schedule now and how
has that
transitioned over time yeah and
well i've been getting the best sleep of
my life now that
la is shut down i guess all of
california which isn't uh
super great for my you know hustle
mentality i guess
but um no it's it's it's been good i can
you know sleep like midnight to eight
you know
there's a little bit of flexibility in
there but and what did you
used to do you used to sleep eight hours
uh
well no i mean especially with no day
ever looked
like the next one i would just fit it in
where i could
and uh early mornings with productions
and late nights and a lot of
hollywood culture going until two three
in the morning and then you don't go to
bed till four
and it was just really inconsistent and
then you you know
had a whole lot to get ready for and get
up early and for hair and makeup and all
these things that you had to do
hours before everybody else so no i'm
getting a lot more sleep these days more
than i probably would like you know you
have these
messages and you're unconscious buried
like if you're sleeping if you're
sleeping eight hours you're not working
hard enough that type of thing so
there has been a little bit of
alleviation as far as
as that goes um but also i'm not missing
anything there's nothing i need to go
out and do that you know or at least i'm
not hearing about it
i i think i think you're doing just fine
with uh with eight hours
uh last question you could ask me one is
aliens are you a believer
or a non-believer oh i believe in
possibility
i i've been i've always just been so
open-minded that it was okay
for me to be wrong with whatever i
thought and also
my conception of if there's aliens if
there's a god
if this or that it doesn't change the
reality of what
actually is so everybody can just have
their opinion
and it's fine right that is i
i would say there's probably intelligent
life out there somewhere
that is a fantastic way to answer that
question and no one has ever answered it
that way
so i will take it what uh what question
you have for me to uh to finish
up well um now that i own some bitcoin
what's next what do i got to do just
wait for a dip buy some more keep buying
bitcoin
everybody uh will come in now that i
bought bitcoin and try to
convince me about other altcoins and
people come in and be like no
no don't do that i will let you make
your own choices
but uh i think that uh what you will
find is that every bitcoiner
uh believes the same two things they
never own enough they don't want the us
dollar price to go up because they want
to buy more of it
so uh it's a very uh interesting dynamic
but uh now look i think it's a it's a
game of accumulation when you have a
finite asset and just dollar cost
averaging right you get your paycheck
and just take whatever percentage
whether it's you know half a percent or
some material percentage and you just
buy bitcoin and convert the dollars into
bitcoin and
keep going right what um what wallet or
platforms do you recommend for me so i
think that
uh for you specifically given that uh
you're coming at this from kind of a
learning perspective
uh i think it's important you learn
about all right so there's a
hardware wallets uh there's kind of cold
storage and then uh
there's uh there's hot storage you can
also use things
uh like block fire to earn interest on
uh on your bitcoin
um but i think that the the key piece is
less about like any one platform
i think it's much more about
understanding you know hey there's four
or five different ways you can custody
the assets
and going and doing it right i think
that's probably like
if i was in your shoes uh and kind of um
very very early on the thing i wish i
had done way earlier than i really did
was go and understand okay what exactly
does cold storage
like how do i do it right because as you
go through that experience after you do
it
you learn a ton right and you learn so
much more than if you would have just
read about it online
then same thing with uh hardware rules
like how do i do it right
if you wanted to get really uh ambitious
you can even set up a bitcoin node right
and again like
if people online for sure you can find
folks who can help you do it but like
going through that process and
understanding how a node works and
uh and why it's important i think would
just give you like the crash course of
actually like the hands-on experience
uh that reading online you just can't
imitate
yeah excellent well that gives me
something to do since like i said i've
got a lot of free time right now so
um but i appreciate all the insights
love watching your podcasts
for sure where can we send people to
find you on the internet if they want to
uh
to reach out or consume some of the
content
yeah follow me twitter instagram
clubhouse
jessica vaughn fawn is v-a-u-g-n
there's no h but yeah that's where you
can find me
awesome listen jessica thank you so much
for doing this let's do it again in the
future
thanks again for uh the great
introductory zoom experience